so many of us are caught up in the rat
race that endless loop of driving to
work toiling away driving back all for
just a few crumbs but behold the literal
rat race in which researchers train
rodents to drive tiny cars surprisingly
unlike for most of us humans the driving
actually seemed to lower the rats stress
levels but maybe that's partly because
at the end if they were good drivers
they got fruit loops to find out more we
talked with researcher Kelly Lambert
about her rodent operated vehicles those
would be our Ovie's and what
implications this might have for humans
so what is this research that you're
carrying out here with rodents we wanted
to teach rats to drive cars so it's a
complex task and so we used some old
fashioned psychological behavioral
training techniques and fruit loops to
shape rats to to get into cars and to
use the car as a as a tool to navigate
an environment to get to that ultimate
reward which is the fruit loop and so we
looked in our most recent study to see
if the complexity of their environments
that they had an enriched environment or
not influenced how quickly they could
learn and it did they walk us through
the experimental setup here we had two
groups one group was housed in an
enriched environment kind of a
Disneyland of sorts for at so they had
different stimuli to interact with and
the other group was into standard
laboratory cages so they had everything
they needed but no Disneyland and so we
were interested in
if the enriched environment would
facilitate their learning to drive we'd
already shown that we could teach the
rats to drive and we also taught them to
steer so we had four were driving bars
and then bars on the left and right so
they could steer in different directions
that they were able to do some pretty
complex turns what made a quote unquote
good rat driver to drive four times for
clean drugs jumping in the car getting
to the fruit loop reward and then coming
back and doing that again so only our
enriched environment animals were able
to do that none of our standard past
animals they could get bits and pieces
of it but they were not able to put it
together
more than one time so our sin that
particular study or standard house
animals did not get a driver's license
have to wait in line again at the DMV to
take better what kinds of vehicles do
you give to a rodent in the lab we had
to build our own so we started with a
basic plastic container and we cut a
window out and put the bars that the
steering bars at the end so that they
could just grab the bars they would
complete the circuit the electrical
circuit although the rats couldn't feel
anything and we added wheels so that's
our rodent operated very simple or you
actually could tell that they might
actually be somewhat enjoying this
process can you talk about how you were
able to measure that so what we did with
this last published study once we taught
them to draw then we took the reward
away it's called extinction trials and
we did that for four days and even the
fourth day after they've been driving
and getting nothing they would still
jump right into the car very quickly
that suggested that they had a positive
association with that so that's one way
we've gotten at this question of is this
a pleasurable experience or a positive
experience the stress card so are a very
glamorous lab that I have we like to
measure stress hormones and rat poop we
can extract the hormones and we look at
a stress hormone that is similar to
cortisol in humans but Accords
corticosteroid and rats and then another
hormone is DHEA is the abbreviation
research suggests the DHEA kind of
buffers against the toxicity of
chronically high stress hormone levels
and throughout the training from all of
the animals in this published group
regardless of whether or not they're in
the standard group or the enriched group
the DHEA to court ratio went up in a
healthy way so that suggests that it's
healthy and then in a previous study
that hasn't been published we had a
different design where we had half the
animals were drivers like we've done
before and then half the animals we
drove them around the same distance with
the same car but did it be a remote
controlled we call those the uber rats
they were just
passenger rats versus the driver rents
and in that study only the driver rats
had the increased DHEA so what comes
next with these rats in your lab are you
gonna make rat race cars SUVs for their
friends a little competition
so we're thinking about neuroplasticity
and getting to the brain measures of
plasticity neuroplasticity refers to the
brain's ability to change to alter
environments or lifestyle so in my lab
we're looking at physical measures I'd
like to look our rats at the end of
their lives they're still alive and
driving and then maybe compare their
brains - brains of rats that did not
receive the training to see if they have
some of those measures of
neuroplasticity we just have to be
careful when we you know maybe
extrapolate what we're finding here with
rodents up to humans but I was working
to talk about you know what this might
suggest about how our own brains might
work when it comes to stimulation and
learning we need engagement with our
physical worlds and our social worlds
and our brains need experience to
develop so I think it can be generalized
or translated to the human brain another
kind of something I thought about is I
wonder since a lot of biomedical
research is conducted on rats and those
standard or in cages if that is
influencing the validity of the results
that we're finding and I think we need
to be looking at more authentic
behaviors and complex behaviors and if
we want to learn about our complex
emotional disorders or cognitive changes
we probably need to look at more complex
research designs so I think we need to
step up our game as scientists and look
at something besides a rat and a mouse
and also look at behaviors beyond
pressing a bar or turning right or left
in a simple maze that because even the
rat brain can do so much more than that
so you saw that there was actually some
enjoyment that these rats were getting
out of learning this new task might that
be kind of the same for humans learning
a new language or
to do cabinetry you know whatever
butcher both absolutely I think that we
have individual differences and what we
like that engaging a different tasks I
think we're interactive can be really
good for the brain so learning is an
enjoyable experience and I think it
gives us a sense that we're gaining
control over our environment a sense of
mastery and this makes us feel better
about you know our bill our competency
in this world so even though it's kind
of a simplistic idea teaching a rat to
drive a car it seems to be taking us
into some complex even philosophical
arenas as we think about what brains can
do thank you for taking the time to chat
with us it's been my pleasure thank you
for your interest in our driving rats
[Music]